my entire team just got locked out looks
like I'm unemployed impersonal and
unsparing as Twitter became its own
Trend just got cut off from laptop
access with virtual Mass sackings from
one of the biggest tech companies in the
world
the email stated that uh if we would be
laid off we'd hear from our to our
personal email and if not to a work
email and it was about an hour after
that I noticed my work laptop was
remotely wiped billionaire Elon Musk who
took over Twitter a week ago described a
massive drop in Revenue as hundreds lost
their jobs without notice it's a form of
cowboy capitalism
good and sophisticated employers that we
would normally deal with wouldn't
conduct themselves in this way it
exposes that even if you're in a Leading
Edge in glamorous working environment to
a degree you're still not far away from
master and servants your employment here
is terminated other big companies have
also sacked staff via video message in
the past 12 months you're
it's at risk of becoming the rule the
very nature of modern work means more of
this a changing world through the
pandemic working from home has
accelerated our use of remote
Communications it was supposedly a shift
towards a better work-life balance but
our interactions have become ever more
impersonal we're now more connected than
ever but those connections are now
seemingly less tangible making it much
easier to cut them off like the Twitter
sackings echoing those of 800 p o
workers they weren't sanctioned in any
way the government could do that they've
got their hands on the levers of power
instead of you know making an example of
piano what they've done here is given
other unscrupulous employees the green
light unions say Twitter have now
announced a consultation but the man
described as a disrupter may be sued for
being too late Adele Robinson Sky News